[Music]
welcome to a dynamic video that will
showcase the national library of
medicine's efforts to support seven
awardees as they use new technology to
raise awareness and disseminate HIV and
AIDS information there is roughly a
million people living with HIV in the US
and one in seven of them don't even know
it
this video world will capture the
innovative process each awardee took to
spread awareness about HIV through
prevention and treatment we will show
you how each awardee organization
created and executed their in eleven
project so let's start with awardees in
the Big Apple New York City he threw up
his arms to the ceiling and looked up
and said there is no cure for AIDS and
there never will be
he said I can't take handling so many
young people dying except I just cannot
take it in 1994 at the height of the
AIDS epidemic paws magazine founded in
New York City was first published pause
it stands for being HIV positive it was
also a time where there was a lot of
death and a lot of suffering so it was a
very bad environment to be tested
positive choreo Gutierrez was diagnosed
with HIV in the 90s and has been an avid
reader of the magazine since its
inception for years and this magazine
has been a resource for him to learn how
to survive with the virus I didn't think
that I would see the age of three
cause the nationwide magazine reaches
over 125,000 people with each issue and
has an online version
pause calm which gets more than 5
million pageviews a half pause covers a
wide spectrum of needs of people living
with and affected by HIV and AIDS but
when it comes to online there's also a
portion of people that we still want to
engage with with better
that's certainly people that are more
tech-savvy
younger people people that are at risk
for HIV who are not necessarily living
with the virus but need more information
HIV and AIDS information from the
National Library of Medicine was a
resource that brought pause and davinci
interactive a nationally recognized
educational technology leader together
the vinci interactive saul pauses strong
Network and suggested interactive
learning to complement pauses online HIV
news interactive learning takes a topic
that is usually text-based and puts it
into a graphical multimedia format it
grabs the users attention it makes them
become involved and make key decisions
really in the learning process
Mesa Scuderi is chief operating officer
for da Vinci with content from NLM and
pause his team was able to create
interactive modules and characters at
the forefront of each story so we start
with the content that's there we pair
that up with visual concepts early on to
see to make sure that both are
consistent and we bring them together
using interactive animation sound
and just to flow through the learning
module itself and getting the user
involved in making key decisions along
the way the information from aide source
in aids info was vital in creating each
module and its associated topic like the
aging module which Katara says has been
especially helpful for him from the
aging module I think what I've taken
away from it the best is the idea of
self empowerment the idea of seeing
people like myself who are living
long-term with the virus and how they've
gotten through the last several decades
feeling that they can talk to their
doctor feeling that they have
information enough to make treatment
decisions a partnership that connects
information and technology together to
help more people hear and see how to
live with HIV when you think of comic
books or graphic novels what immediately
comes to mind batman/superman well for
Digital Illustrator my clearing he sees
a tool to improve somebody's life I am
the illustrator for this project and I
also wrote the scripts for this project
which is an HIV prevention campaign
geared to the Latino community the
campaign is called amigo diamantes and
it's being spearheaded by El Centro a
nonprofit organization that seeks to use
interactive graphic novels the novels
raise awareness of HIV and AIDS for
Latino MSM in New York City Latinos
represent just 17% of
but when it forms to the new cases of
HIV make everything almost 25% of the
cases in the country the entire process
starts with focus groups held with
community members an initial focus group
story was really about message
development we said these are the key
HIV prevention messages this is material
that's posted at the national library
vest website here's a broad picture of
what we're thinking we're gonna do it's
gonna be an online comic book with
voices and speech bubbles and sometimes
there might be choice points where the
action will stop and you'll decide for a
character whether they should or
shouldn't do something vital input from
community members coupled with the
National Library of medicines resources
kick start the script writing and
character development process with a
focus on culturally relatable content
they also need information that is
appropriate for them that comes from
their experiences where the characters
actually looked like they that they feel
identified with those characters a task
that was near and dear to the heart of
illustrator Mike Leary having several
Latino friends and also living in a
Latino community in wood in Manhattan it
was very special to me once the art was
finished content development began a key
focus was to seamlessly integrate NLM
health education into the story we came
up with what we call sort of a circle of
friends structure so there's one main
character and then these spokes that
come out from him so we know that he's
questioning he's in the city he's having
sex with men and
but he's also got a friend who's openly
out and he's got a cousin who's having
problems in her relationship harnessing
the power of compelling stories to
inspire readers to fill and think deeply
about health issues that directly affect
them nestled between Philadelphia and
Pittsburgh sits the capital city of
Pennsylvania Harrisburg beyond having
the unique distinction as the training
center for the Union Army during the
Civil War and the present location of
the National Civil War Museum Harrisburg
now serves as home to a new organization
fighting a new battle black girl health
black girl health is a digital
publishing company our mission is to
transform everyday minority women into
healthier individuals we focus our
efforts on social media online
commercials and community outreach in
2015 black girl health I saw a great
success on Facebook using articles and
creating a newscast to disseminate NLM
information and resources as part of the
pop the question
HIV awareness campaign pop the question
is really just women taking control of
their sexual health when you think of
pop the question you probably think of a
man getting down on one knee and asking
their partner to marry them instead this
is the woman maybe not getting down on
her knee but asking that man to go get
tested using HIV information from aids
source in MedlinePlus BGH expanded their
pop the question campaign in 2016 to
another social media network frequently
used by the target audience instagram
social media assistant Ashley Manning
converted text-based NLM articles to
short format videos then publish those
videos weekly on the BGH instagram page
for its followers HIV is definitely
- the topic is something that a lot of
people don't feel comfortable talking
about there's definitely a huge stigma
around HIV in the minority community so
bringing this information to them on
social media through video it makes them
feel more comfortable sharing it and
talking about it with others to help in
the fight to raise awareness vgh
recruited help from social-media
influencer miss JV and so how many women
have you been with ladies are you unsure
about your man's HIV status if so it
might be time to pop the question
visit black girl health calm today and
we'll show you how bringing comedy to a
topic that isn't fun to talk about
really made the content more engaged
capitalizing on the viral reach of the
video MS J instructed her following to
navigate to the bgh website where they
could fill out a survey evaluating their
knowledge of HIV and how to pop the
question they opened up the avenue for
us to have a dialogue about how to pop
the question when to pop the question if
you have popped the question correctly
VG ages staff assistant Carlie Cureton
played an integral role in turning our
digital interactions with minority women
into real-world actions at black or a
health second annual kickstart Health
and Wellness Expo the increased
awareness of NLM's HIV information on
social media encouraged women to not
only attend the expo but garnered
several on-site testings as well showing
once and for all in the battle for
minority women's health in Harrisburg
allies proved more powerful than
obstacles
[Music]
HIV is a tide the Tidewater region has
not been able to turn Norfolk State
University is helping lead the community
out of the rocky waters with project
choice project choice is an HIV
education and Prevention Program so the
choices for choosing healthy options and
challenging America the university
program has focused on meeting the
health needs of African Americans by
using technology to access information I
think the mission of this project is
really in line with the overall mission
of project choice which is to not only
educate students and community members
that we engage with but to try to
prevent the spread of HIV to disseminate
information from the National Library of
Medicine engineer student Couture Cod
well created an iBook you're able to put
an iBook together through of course the
software iBooks Author Cod well says
multiple widgets are in the software
which provide the ability to include
interactive media such as audio and
video that the reader can play some of
which are recorded skits from theater
students in our state you speak but what
we six what part is exactly like where
my exhibition I can't help but feel as
though all men up to no good and I never
tried to actually listen to what you're
doing and what you're saying so I took
the role as being this ideal aggressive
woman
had been sexually harassed violate it
you name protect yourself
don't neglect yourself eight info and
MedlinePlus where the resources used to
bring context to the scripts she became
informed with the prep the information
of HIV how to go get help
and who to talk to where to go so on and
so forth and her character changed so
embedded in the iBook are questions that
they asked and then it gives you the
right answer to tell you whether you're
right or wrong
so that's embedded in several of the
chapters to make sure that people are
understanding what they're reading
project choice realizes the real test is
outside the boundaries of campus life
and in the community Cynthia Burwell is
tasked with taking the iBook to the
church' the church helps to reach the
people they will be trained on how to
use the iBook for Age AIDS and HIV
education in their churches they will be
able to use it with different groups in
their churches to provide up-to-date
information
NLM information that's helping give an
innovative lifeline to protect the
Tidewater community
[Music]
you have just seen how innovative
projects on the East Coast are fighting
the HIV epidemic with NLM educational
tools community outreach organizations
colleges tech and digital companies
print and online publications are all
playing an integral role in making a
difference so now we're going to visit
organizations and communities further
west starting in the Windy City Chicago
Illinois where there's an increase of
HIV AIDS related cases among African
American men at the close of 2015 more
than 24,000 people were living with HIV
in Chicago Illinois proactive a local
nonprofit organization is on the front
lines training and equipping community
health workers on how to deal with the
HIV epidemic
there are actually four institutions
involved two community-based
institutions and two academic
institutions one is south suburban
college and that's out here and that's a
two-year institution and the other is
Chicago State University these step up
students will eventually become
community health workers helping
residents by educating them on HIV
prevention and treatment methods through
the use of tablets I know that in the
future with the career choice that I've
chosen this is going to be a great tool
for me because the information that I
share will be from a reliable source
proactive will train 93 step up students
on NLM resources this will be part of an
interactive digital lesson plan
Interactive's healthcare readiness
program I thought that I had the
resources that I needed to talk about
HIV but as I began to go on this
particular website I learned more
and more and it was more truthful and
accurate information
the tablets community health workers
learn to navigate NLM resources on will
prove useful and off-site partner
organizations allowing them the
opportunity to meet people where they
are with vital and accurate HIV
prevention and commitment information we
have high-risk populations so they are
hard to find hard to locate but our team
has really been able to go in there and
do segmented outreach and locate those
individuals that are positive increasing
numbers of qualified health care workers
to meet the increasing need to treat HIV
patients on any given day one to two
hundred people pass through the Mexican
Consulate in Salt Lake City Utah and a
good portion of those people are just
waiting and there's absolutely nothing
there to do they just sit there and
stare at the wall pretty much so we use
that time with a predominant donor or a
community health worker and they take
full advantage of it transforming
waiting time into a meaningful health
learning experience the biggest way that
HIV has affected our community members
is a fact that it's not something that
we talk about and it's not something
that we necessarily know about getting
pertinent health information from a
familiar face also makes a big impact on
those served when O'Donnell información
Park employee Marilyn plus a unit
working block muchas personas no Tina no
seguro médico insufficient and a pagina
Isola failure
I missed again it was icy let's say you
have a stunt and America mentos okay
this is no side the Muslim numbers raros
and to say just a few can that travel
information they may have never come
across due to the language barriers they
face in the US and cultural barriers
they face back home we invite them into
them and any other salud to get tested
we do blood pressure glucose and B in my
testing and at the end of every person
coming into getting the testing we do a
one-on-one session to go over the
websites again to reinforce that these
websites are available to them to get
hiv/aids info but also other health
related information they've connected
over 300 people to health resources with
the help of the National Library of
Medicine including Syria
Alvarez there is one website in
particular that Alejandra showed me
where you can find like HIV testing
places by like putting in your zip code
and it's really cool
from those surveys we've been able to
realize that the work that dart
promoters are doing is valuable and it
works because we see an increase of
knowledge from the before and after of
our committee members when to receive
the workshop and are able to access
their resources assisting yet another
person to their right to life liberty
and the pursuit of healthiness
[Music]
the year 2014 the transgender tipping
point from the red carpet and the runway
to politics and entertainment
transgender people truly were everywhere
but for many transgender youth the
notoriety has not created impactful
change in their daily lives nowhere is
that more apparent than in the area of
health care transgender youth they have
challenges they have requirements and
they don't know where to go to get a
questions answered they don't know where
to go to get services that are youth
friendly with providers that understand
the needs that are quite unique for the
transgender community headquartered in
the bay area of California the mecca of
LGBTQ rights y th is the partner of
choice for those in search of new ways
to advance health of youth and young
adults through technology in addition to
those health disparities and youth are
also kind of faced with their depend on
their parents they don't necessarily
have an income so if they come out to
their parents and they're not receiving
support where you go from there and that
is why they developed they choose e a
mobile app that brings together all the
Bay Area resources for transgender
spectrum youth so the design itself was
really guided by our brainstorming
process and meeting with the transgender
youth community and our advisory board
so that sort of kicked off the design
process where we got feedback from them
on what they would like to see in the
app when somebody uses the app and they
are searching for a certain answer a
certain search term a lot of the
resources that end up coming up are
actually NLM resources the app is
available in the Apple or Android app
store and has features that allow you to
find community hangouts testing sites
and doctors like dr. Scott Moser
internationally-renowned board-certified
plastic surgeon based in san francisco
so any individual that's looking for an
HIV doctor again blood pressure doctor
or a diabetes doctor for any reason but
wants to make sure that their
gender-inclusive
and an understanding of their potential
to their needs as well those are the
individuals of all be easily have giving
Bay Area transgender youth their moment
for a better life you have just saved
the technical processes each ACI Opie
awardee took to disseminate NLM HIV
information DaVinci upgraded a
conventional print magazine with a
scenario based a learning module
interwoven with resources from NLM El
Centro used interactive graphic novels
to disseminate NLM information black
oral health
use an influential social media
celebrity to bring minority women
together to learn about NLM information
resources Norfolk State University
developed eye books that combined
Dramatic Arts with NLM information to
engage youth proactive community
services engaged students pursuing
health careers to use tablets to become
proficient with NLM resources
communities United use the Mexican
Consulate as a Technology Center to
educate spanish-speaking immigrants on
NLM resources and HIV information and
lastly why th served transgender youth
by developing a mobile phone app using
NLM information to meet the special
needs of this population after showing
all the technical approaches used to
disseminate NLM resources we hope you
see the awardees as key stakeholders
that align their efforts to address an
ongoing health crisis in addition the
National Library of Medicine as an
emerging leader in innovative approaches
to raising awareness around HIV and AIDS
we like to think in a limb for
cutting-edge technology to support HIV
and AIDS prevention and treatment
information as well as supporting each
awardees creative uses of NLM's
resources
[Music]
[Applause]